- You're going to learn three ways
to be seen as the leader in the room
and we're gonna reverse engineer this.
As we look at these top three
skill sets you'll notice
if you think about the
best leaders you know,
this is how they show up.
And once you know what they're doing,
you can improve those same skills.
So let's assume you're
not the official leader
in the room every time yet.
How can you establish yourself
as an obvious emerging
leader in that group?
And I have just one caveat,
before I give you the top three,
I'm assuming that you're
already good and competent
at your actual individual
job responsibilities.
In no way should we ever
view communication skills
as a way to hide your
shortcomings or incompetence,
your knowledge, skills and
expertise are prerequisites.
And if these sound like the kind of skills
you want to get better at, I
encourage you to take a look
at my Communication Coach Academy.
We offer classes and group
coaching on communication skills,
public speaking and leadership.
There's a link in the
description below this video.
Now let's talk about three ways
to come across like a leader.
And if you think of some additional ways
to be seen as a leader,
then please leave that in the comments
and we look forward to reading your tips.
First, leaders solve problems.
When the best leaders see a need,
they take initiative, they take action.
In contrast, many non-leader see a problem
and they're great about
talking about the problem,
maybe complaining, pointing the fingers
and expecting other people
to solve the problem.
But the leader in the room
is the one who recommends
possible solutions
and offers to take action.
And problem solvers have a
specific and learnable skillset.
You have to be able to look at a problem,
diagnose the possible
causes of that problem
and recommend a solution.
As part of that, leaders must
be able to make decisions.
That doesn't mean you need
to make decisions instantly
or without thought,
but I will say this, a
pattern of indecisiveness
won't demonstrate your leadership.
So here's a tip within a tip,
when you suggest solutions,
be ready to break those solutions down
into a few action steps.
A leader might say, for
example, "These are three steps
to solving this problem."
And then you would concisely
spell out those three steps,
that demonstrates that
you thought carefully
about the solution.
And by providing a solution
and a course of action,
other people will literally
be following your plan
and that comes across
as an obvious problem solving
leadership moment for you.
Other people notice that.
So tip one, you'll come
across like a leader
if you solve problems.
Second, leaders are good with groups.
The best leaders make
contributions to group discussions
in three ways,
effective leaders make contributions
on the task related work at meetings.
So everything you say should
add value and be helpful
in one way or another.
Specifically, most leaders stay on topic
and don't go on tangents.
Leaders offer their point of view
or provide helpful information
on the task at hand
and if a conversation gets off track,
it's the leader's job to get
the conversation back on track.
Now on this topic, I want
to offer a word of caution.
Some people mistakenly believe
that the leader is the person
who should talk the most
at most meetings.
that could be the case in some situations
if you're already the
official leader in the room.
However, if there's already
an official leader there,
you should not talk more than they do
and you shouldn't even be
the second place talker,
we'll call it.
If you were in a class in
college or high school,
then you might remember how people respond
when one person talks
more than anyone else,
it doesn't create a great vibe
for the other students or for the teacher
and you obviously don't
want to be the quietest
or most reserved person in the group.
When it comes to task
related conversations,
you want to be right in the middle
and contribute about an average amount.
Another way leaders
demonstrate their effectiveness
in groups is by excelling
at relationship oriented communication.
Effective leaders take the
time to connect socially
with politeness and small talk
before the meeting officially kicks off.
They don't isolate themselves
in the presence of the group,
in other words, and
during the meeting itself,
they invest in relationships
by encouraging other people.
Now, another word of caution
on this, don't overdo it.
You don't want to focus so much on
how everybody's doing that
it becomes a preoccupation,
like, "Is everybody doing okay?"
"Does anyone need anything?"
"Is everybody comfortable
and feeling attended to?"
If you make taking care of other people
in the group your main focus,
you may be unintentionally
positioning yourself
as a merely supportive person
in the meeting, not a leader.
The cure for this
is to make plenty of task
related contributions
and be generally considerate of others,
but not preoccupied by
other people's needs.
The next key way leaders
are good with groups
is they develop a skill of
facilitating the conversation.
Here are some ways that you can do this.
You can ask good questions,
if there are quiet members in the group,
but you can tell they
have something to say,
help them get into the
conversation a little bit.
If the conversation is
too long or drifting,
you can refocus the discussion
by synthesizing the key themes
or main points you've heard
and then reflect that back to the group.
You could say,
for example, "It sounds like
we have three main concerns."
And then you would list those
three concerns concisely.
Listening carefully
and crystallizing the discussion like this
is an incredibly valuable
group facilitation skill.
So number two, you look
like a leader in the room
if you're good with groups.
Third, leaders are
effective communicators,
or at least most leaders are.
And when leaders are at their best,
they're prepared, clear and concise
and if you do this, you'll
come across like a leader.
When you give a status
update in front of the team,
make sure you have your key
points sketched out beforehand.
Talk through your outline a
few times before the meeting
to make sure you're crisp and on point.
Another way leaders demonstrate
effective communication
is through the power of public speaking.
When you're doing a standup
presentation for any reason,
that's a leadership moment for you.
Make the most of it by preparing days
or even weeks in advance if
it's an important presentation.
And let's not forget good listening.
There's an expression that
leaders are listeners.
You can show that you're a good
listener by paying attention
and taking notes when other people speak.
I had a supervisor for
years who took notes
during every single one-on-one
conversation we had.
In contrast, if you were
to communicate well,
when it's your turn to talk
and then look at your device or tune out
when other people are speaking,
you won't come across as a leader.
You have to learn to listen carefully,
even when the topic seems
to have nothing to do
with your area of expertise.
In summary, if you want to come across
as the leader in the room,
start working on solving problems,
get better at working in groups,
and work on your communication
skills at all levels.
That's what the best leaders do.
Knowing that, you can reverse engineer it
and help yourself come
across like a leader,
starting right away.
And in that spirit, I wanted to tell you
about my Communication Coach Academy.
There are free resources on the website
and we also offer classes, group coaching,
and amazing communication templates
that will drastically
speed up your progress,
and lots of other resources.
If you wanna take a look,
there's a link to the academy
in the description below the video
and it's also pinned in the first comment
in the comment section.
Speaking of which, I would love
to hear any advice you have
about showing up as
the leader in the room.
Make your suggestion in
the comment section below.
Until next time, thanks, God
bless, and I will see you soon.